i believe that climate change is the
moral test of our times
it's not just about the environment it's
about human rights
and justice it's about taking
responsibility for fellow human beings
and translating that into action
ceres operates in central america an
underdeveloped region
of the world that despite contributing
very little
to the causes of climate suffers some of
the worst consequences
last year in the midst of the pandemic
two
hurricanes hit the country can you
imagine having to decide
whether to save your house and your
crops from the floods
or whether you can contract covey at a
shelter
our work supports young people from the
most vulnerable communities
to organize and begin to take action
to build resilience to protect our
ecosystems and to reduce climate
vulnerability
just in the past three years 50 000
young people joined the movement every
day
working in actions such as reforestation
campaigns
educational environmental education
human rights access to water food
sovereignty
and many others if the rest of the world
could follow their example
i know that we could achieve the 17
sustainable development goals
you